it seems like the change was in ambition
the University of Houston today is a
more ambitious university than it was 12
years ago
absolutely you no doubt what did it take
financially to get there so of course if
you can get some financial support is
always very good we don't have a large
endowment for the size of student body
or endowment is not much is 900 million
and we have 46,000 students right now we
don't have any other form of income
either like you could have oil money or
something we don't have that either so
what that meant was we had to hustle we
had to be creative we had to find
partners and we have to collaborate with
all these institutions in Houston to
really find that synergy right now we
are very much in sync with the energy
industry there are CEOs presidents they
serve on the energy advisory board
helping us there the member of the Texas
Medical Center and as a result now we
just started medical school and just now
looking to get national accreditation
but in the course of the University of
Houston's new ambitions tuition went up
more than 50% room and board went up
more than 50% student fees also went up
about 50% why was it necessary to do
that so you could say that we are
ambitious University but you can take a
look at all across in higher education
whether that has been a trend now I
would say you would say the support and
services went up 100% you would say that
financial aid has gone up very
significantly as well and
just the opportunities that the students
have that has gone up as well so why
couldn't you do what you wanted to do
and this is a question that you're
answering because you're courageous but
that stands for the entire field of
higher education why did it take a
tuition increase and an increase in fees
and in room and board to do the things
you wanted to do on campus here so first
you have to understand the state
budgeting for universities it's not like
you can increase the tuition and do the
many things that we talked about or you
can put the money in athletics for
instance or you can put the money here
and there you know it or building
medical school for instance none of
those things you can touch with tuition
money anyway right the over the same
time period in 12 years the state budget
for university and not just mine I'm
talking across the across the United
States
the state's investment in universities
has gone down significantly however if
you think that universities are
basically used to to fill that gap
that's not true either because tuition
has not filled that entire gap tuition
has not filled the gap know what our
fees and the rest of it no I mean all
together the universities have worked
very hard and not just mine I mean I'm
just telling you across all types of
universities they work very hard to also
create efficiency so if you look at it
the dollar per student from a state they
are nowhere at what the support was
earlier so that's one reason but let me
just
one other thing that must be taken into
consideration and that is what is
expected from a university today that
wasn't actually expected maybe 12 years
or 15 years ago to give you one example
a state mental health counseling
universities have invested you all
across a lot of money in trying to
address the issues that were not on top
of their list at that time there are
issues homelessness or hunger all of
these kinds of things are much more
expanded services and support that
universities were not expected to take
let's say 10 or 15 years ago because we
have switched our mission from not just
access that we are here for you come and
enroll we have actually switched our
focus to success which means how our
point is our mission is to see what can
we do to make sure that you are
successful and as a result you can see
that our Normand has grown yes but at
the same time we used to have graduation
rate forty percent graduation rate
six-year in today's 61 percent and we
are shooting towards 70% the four-year
is still in the 30s yes so 40 is so it's
going to come now still below average
yes and but the six years now is where
the expected is but let's just talk
about not just University of Houston I'm
just talking about but so on the subject
of an issue that affects many big public
universities you're right
but just because state funding has
fallen doesn't mean you have to then
pass on that cost to students and
Families that's a choice right so
you're absolutely right it's a choice
the state the reduction in funding has
not been passed on to their students
that's what I'm saying because the
tuition because if you look at the rise
in tuition all across and if you look at
the reduction in a state funding the two
don't match up there's a formal
reduction in a state then there is a
rise in tuition and that gap has been
made by efficiencies that universities
have created by doing all kinds of
things by collaborating by consolidating
things I can see my colleagues working
day and night at institutions trying to
worry about tuition and I am very I am
very empathetic and sympathetic because
when I went to school myself here my
husband had to take second job and then
third job to pay for my tuition and I
almost dropped out so these students
here clearly face that challenge if they
do drop out if they drop out for
financial reason we try to make sure so
here you can go for free if your family
income is up to fifty thousand but I
want to talk about that
yes but beyond that also we hand out so
much more in financial aid today than we
were doing it before and we are still
enrolling one of the most diverse
student bodies in the country and some
of the students particularly at-risk
students they can be successful but they
required lot more hand-holding a lot
more personalized attention so we had to
increase in terms of number advisors and
I'm not just talking about me I know
some of my colleagues who have done even
far greater job than what we've done
here at the
stupid stuff so what I hear you saying
is that tuition has gone up and room and
board and fees have all gone up because
you have expanded services like
counseling and support and because
students need more help to graduate on
time definitely but the support in terms
of room and board if you think about it
we always look at it was there was the
rental cost outside the university
because my board will never let us raise
the price of you know ball boarding here
or staying here if the market you know
doesn't bear that it's not outside but
the market is part of the problem are
you running here a business or a school
well you think about it some of the
universities get about 5% or 10% support
from estates so you ask yourself how do
you run something you know no I'm just
saying you have to be you have to be
sensitive to both sides of it so
American University let's talk for a
second there are double mission for
universities that are research
universities like you know ourselves
American higher education is absolutely
the jewel and the asset and the most
sought-after product of America from
America I mean people who still want to
come here for education why because the
quality is so
now you want to make sure that you can
balance the 2x which is you want to make
sure that you keep your institutions
absolutely excellent and top-notch in
the work they have to be globally
competitive but the same time you
fulfill the mission of teaching I mean
the the as many students as possible so
you are looking at breadth but you're
also looking at depth and excellence and
you have to balance both of those things